Let's look at the solution for our laundry
pipelining quiz. We have a washer, dryer and
folder. Each takes one hour. We have ten
loads of laundry. With no pipelining, one load takes
three hours to finish. Only then we begin
the next load. So it's going to take 30 hours
to do them, because we do them one
at a time. Each takes three hours. With pipelining,
the first load will take one, two, three hours. So, so far we are no better off.
However, once the first load is in the folder, the second load is already in the
dryer. When the first load leaves the pipeline
after three hours, it takes only one hour to
do the folding for the next load. So
we have, after the initial three hours, one load
leaving every hour. So what we have, really,
is three hours for the first load, plus
one hour for the remaining loads. Overall, it
takes only 12 hours to process the ten loads.
As you can see, by planning, you can
significantly improve the execution time, when we have many
things to do. And, when you have instructions,
you usually have a lot of them to do.